il est nécessaire de prendre une
décision attendue depuis longtemps de
reconnaître immédiatement l'indépendance
et la souveraineté de la république
populaire de joliette et de la
république populaire de l'ouganda
s'agisse problème ce n'est pas une
première c'est même la troisième fois
que la russie reconnaît officiellement
l'indépendance d'un territoire
appartenant à l'une des quinze
républiques de l'ex urss et territoires
née d'un conflit civil avec le pouvoir
central reconnu uniquement entre eux et
par très peu d'autres pays et surtout
soutenu par moscou c'est le cas de
l'ossétie du sud pour la communauté
internationale c'est une région de
géorgie mais dans les faits la
république à des frontières un président
un drapeau et des institutions c'est en
1992 que la région se déclare
indépendante à la suite d'un référendum
en 2008 une guerre de cinq jours éclate
avec l'armée géorgienne la russie
intervient un accord de paix s'ensuit
moscou reconnaît alors l'indépendance de
l'ossétie du sud
pour le plus grand bonheur des habitants
autre portion de la géorgie inféodés au
kremlin l'abkhazie mais 1600 kilomètres
carrés entre le caucase et la mer noire
elle aussi proclame son indépendance par
référendum en 1999 un référendum jugé
illégal par l'onu et c'est en même temps
que sa jumelle l'ossétie du sud en 2008
que moscou déclare le territoire
indépendant
autre poche pro russe coincée entre la
moldavie et l'ukraine la transnistrie
c'est en 1992 que la région déclare son
indépendance cette fois la russie ne
suis pas pas officiellement mais la
région vit sous perfusion russe moscou
lui assure aussi un soutien militaire la
mère patrie protège le territoire avec
au moins un millier d'hommes
trente ans après la chute de l'urss ces
régions d'europe de l'est sont restés le
jardin de moscou état fantôme figé dans
l'ère soviétique